♪ ♪ ♪
- Ils étaient au parc Jarry
pour une marche. Mais pas
seulement.
- Dire aussi que les aînés,
on est réveillés!
- Et qu'ils ont des
revendications. Parmi les voeux
formulés :
- La gratuité pour les
transports oui, parce que c'est
pas tous les aînés qui ont
une certaine aisance.
- Exaucé d'un côté...
VALÉRIE PLANTE, candidate à la
mairie de Montréal
- Rendre le transport collectif
gratuit.
- Comme de l'autre...
JEAN AIROLDI, candidat
d'Ensemble Mtl, L'Île-des-Soeurs
- La gratuité du transport en
commun pour les personnes
de 65 ans et plus.
- Mais les convergences entre
Valérie Plante et Denis Coderre
ne s'arrêtent pas là.
DENIS CODERRE, candidat mairie
de Mtl chef, Ensemble Montréal
- Le report du surplus de taxes
foncières.
- Le report d'impot foncier pour
les personnes aînées, voilà.
- Jetrouve c'est important
le parc, c'est important de
sortir de chez soi.
- Exaucé, aussi.
- Profiter des installations
récréatives qui sont mises
de l'avant.
STÉPHANIE VALENZUELA, candidate
d'Ensemble Mtl, Côte-Des-Neiges
- D'équipements sportifs adaptés
aux ainés dans les parcs.
- Il ne faudrait pas qu'il y ait
de distance entre
les générations.
- Et donc, mieux faire entendre
la voix des aînés. L'Équipe
Denis Coderre mettra sur pied
une instance et rappelle que
déjà, en 2018...
GAETANA COLELLA, candidate
d'Ensemble Mtl Sault-au-Récollet
- Ensemble Montréal déposait
une motion pour créer un conseil
des aînés que l'administration
Plante a malheureusement choisi
de ne pas adopter.
- Mais aujourd'hui,
l'engagement...
- C'est de créer un conseil
des doyennes et des doyens
de Montréal.
- Autre chose qui améliorerait
la qualité de vie des personnes
plus âgées?
- Ne serait-ce qu'au niveau de
la sécurité, de la circulation.
- Elles font partie des piétons
les plus vulnérables.
- 55 % des piétons qui sont
décédés étaient agés de 65 ans
et plus.
- Un plan de sécurisation et
d'entretien des trottoirs est
notamment sur la table.
- Et il y a du travail. Exemple,
ce trottoir abîmé dans Côte-des-
Neiges.
- Je suis déjà tombée à cause
d'un trou, je l'avais pas vu là.
- Une réparation de cette
section, par l'arrondissement,
est prévue pour 2022 ou 2023
seulement.
(alarme de sirène)
- La ville-centre, pourtant,
vient de refaire la rue,
juste devant.
- C'est le manque
de considération pour
les piétons je dirais.
- En fait, c'est plutôt
le manque d'arrimage entre
les deux niveaux de décision.
Car les piétons, et en
particulier les aînés, seront
un électorat très courtisé
pour le 7 novembre.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio Canada, M